chrissy teigen and john legend welcomed
a baby girl April 14 and announced the
exciting news on Sunday via social media
our new love is here we couldn't be
happier John tweeted ET caught up with
producer Mike Jackson at the underground
panel Saturday he and legend both
executive produced the show Jackie says
he's already met little luna Simone I've
held baby Luna in my arms she is
absolutely beautiful yes he and chris
here at home right now kind of first
stayed home with the baby getting used
to that and i think i got home late last
night and yeah we're all really excited
and proud and that's a new dad just days
after giving birth chrissy joked about
how her hubby is doing after Labor
tweeting to everyone asking John is
healing perfectly they're happy they're
related there's a long time coming they
went through a lot to have this child
and they're excited we're all really
blessed that she's a part of all of our
lives and yeah we're excited I'll let
them talk about baby Luna she looks like
both of them she's gorgeous